hi it's Michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and
today we're doing something a little bit different
I recently saw this list of top products mentioned
on the skincareaddiction subreddit on Reddit
I don't know how many people know
this but I actually used to be a
moderator there from 2014 till 2019 so
I'm really familiar with these products
and I thought it would be interesting
to do like a tier ranking list which
I've seen Anthony fantano and James
Welsh and tons of other people do
we're going to go through reddit's top 15
products and put them onto this tier which
goes from Holy Grail all the way down
to not for anyone and then below that
I've got like a little area which is
products that I haven't actually tried
as usual these are my opinions on
the products my skin is not your
skin don't stop using a product
you love because I didn't like it
so this list of most discussed products
on skincareaddiction it's from a site
called looria and it's from the last
year so the mentions can be good or
bad it's not really distinguished so I would
expect most of them are good mentions though
okay so our first product is the CeraVe
hydrating cleanser and this is pretty
much no surprise CeraVe is like reddit's
favorite skincare brand it makes sense it
fits in with a lot of needs of the people
from the skincareaddiction demographic
so from a 2017 survey I don't think there's
a newer one most of the people on there are
female which is the case with pretty much
anything skincare but also in their 20s
so cerave's products are very budget
friendly Reddit is a largely us-based
site and CeraVe is really easy to
get pretty much anywhere in the US
lots of people end up on skincareaddiction
because they're looking for solutions to
their acne and this is recommended by tons of
dermatologists for that because it's really
it's suitable for such a wide range of people it's
fragrance free they're very inoffensive formulas
Reddit users are generally more focused on
effectiveness of skin care products rather
than enjoyment most people go there to
try to fix a problem with their skin
Reddit is also a text-based site and so
there's a lot more info is on information
rather than anything aesthetic like
something like Instagram or TikTok
I think they're fine they're a very safe
recommendation if you're looking for
plain products but I do kind of just find
them a little bit boring a bit joyless I
prefer a more sensory experience with my
skincare I like things that feel nice and
smell nice so yeah they're good but I find it
difficult to actually get excited about them
so the hydrating cleanser I think one of the
reasons it is so popular is because it is
non-foaming so there is this very popular myth
that foaming cleansers dehydrate your skin and
this has been around for ages and it still
persists I've talked about this before in
my video about cleanser myths more foam doesn't
necessarily mean less gentle and more stripping
there are lots of ways to boost foam in a
cleanser without just turning to harsh surfactants
back in the day I think this was more of an
issue because the only real way that people
made cleansers foam was by adding more
sodium lauryl sulfate which tends to be
drying unless it's formulated carefully so
I think this myth is still around because
of more old school skincare experts and
also just like Legacy information online
so this is a good cleanser it is really
hydrating the name CeraVe actually comes
from ceramides and multivesicular technology
and both of these are about moisturizing
ceramides are substances in your
skin that contribute to that Skin
Barrier and CeraVe products contain
them to replenish anything that's
lost so it's meant to restore them
for more moisturized less dry skin
the multivesicular technology part is about
having moisturizing ingredients in little
packages with multiple layers around them
and so that means that these vesicles sit
on your skin and slowly release the
moisturizing ingredients over time
so you have prolonged moisturizing
after you've used a CeraVe product
now I don't know how much of this technology is
going to last after you've washed the cleanser off
but it does have a lot of hydrating ingredients
which at least will keep your skin hydrated when
you're cleansing which is one of the more
compromising steps in a skincare routine
when your skin becomes a bit more vulnerable
this cleanser is not my favorite of their range
it is a fatty alcohol-based formula that comes out
a bit like a kind of gel it doesn't foam and I do
have a preference for foaming cleansers I just
prefer how nice they are to spread over my face
I do like the pump and I like that pretty much
all CeraVe cleansers come in pumps I think this is
also popular because it is cerave's recommendation
for dry skin a lot of people on skincareaddiction
again end up there because they have acne
and so many acne treatments are quite drying
so there's things like row Accutane which is the
oral drug which dries out your skin quite a lot
people are maybe using tretinoin or adapling or
different or even benzoyl peroxide and all of
these will dry out your skin and so you kind of
want a cleanser that isn't going to strip more
I have oily skin and so cerave's recommendation is
different so I was always bound to not like this
one as much but it is really solid for people with
dry skin so I'm going to put it in solid Choice
all right the next product is the CeraVe
moisturizing cream so this is called the
CeraVe in the tub on Reddit yes CeraVe have
a lot of moisturizers in their range and a
lot of them have very similar names and
similar color coding again this is for
dry skin and with the skincareaddiction
demographic it makes sense that this is
so popular this formula hasn't changed
much since CeraVe started I think the
biggest change was that they took out
parabens around 2020 for marketing reasons
every once in a while people will freak out
about parabens and then discover that the
CeraVe that their dermatologist recommended
is full of poison this is not true I have a
video on why clean beauty is BS but it
happens all the time and I think it is
happening on TikTok probably right now so
it makes sense from a commercial angle to
get rid of parabens I guess as much as I hate it
because parabens are really safe preservatives
this has a really nice mix of moisturizing
ingredients there's my favorite glycerin there's
things like petrolatum and dimethicone
which are occlusives they help seal in
moisture so you have the ceramides you have
phytosphingosine which is an ingredient that is
meant to mimic what's already in your skin there's
cholesterol which again is already in your skin
now there is this problem with this product
which is closed comedones some people just
get tons of these with it closed comedones
are like little uninflamed pimples so you can
squeeze out white stuff but it doesn't
go red a lot of the time we call these
clogged pores and a lot of people put this
down to the fatty alcohols in the product
I'm not sure if that is the case it's the cetearyl
alcohol but yeah it does seem to be a problem
so I'm going to put this again in solid choice
because I think it is a good recommendation for
most people even if it's not super suitable
for my skin which is more on the oily side
okay on to product three which is the
CeraVe foaming cleanser this one is my
preferred CeraVe cleanser it's good
for oily skin it is quite hydrating
so it turns out there are a couple of different
versions of this the one I tried I bought in an
Australian store so that is the Australian
and European version which has coco-betaine
as the first surfactant there is a different
version which is sold in the US and UK and
that has cocamidopropyl hydroxysultaine
as the first surfactant I haven't tried
that one yet I'll have to try to track it down
the one I'm reviewing here is the coco-betaine
I was feeling pretty silly about not noticing
this earlier but then I saw that the official
Australian CeraVe website got confused it
has us reviews on it so I stopped feeling bad
it's got a nice mix of ingredients so
it's got some really gentle surfactants
that aren't really harsh or stripping it's
called coco-betaine it's got sodium cocoyl
glycinate both of these are really quite
hydrating surfactants we also have the
standard moisturizing ingredients that
CeraVe puts in pretty much all of their
products so glycerin ceramides hyaluronic
acid I'm going to put this in solid Choice
the reason is I don't like the way it
smells and you know how some things
smell like chemicals which I hate saying
because I am a chemist but that is what it
smells like it's like really artificial
slightly plasticky smell I do like it
it's just going to be bumped down to
solid choice because I don't love it
then we have a couple of other CeraVe products
we've got the CeraVe daily moisturizing lotion
and we have the CeraVe PM facial moisturizing I
haven't tried either of these so I'm going to put
these down in no opinion but to be honest I think
they would probably be pretty safe in solid Choice
the next product is the Paula's Choice BHA
liquid so this is the two percent salicylic
acid and I don't think this is any surprise
but it is going straight up in the Holy Grails
for me because this product I have been using
it since 2009 I've not stopped using it since
then this is like a legacy cult product
that has been popular since before 2009
the reason I bought it was because I
saw so many rave reviews of it on the
internet back then and I think back then the
biggest influence was probably makeupalley
this is just a really good salicylic acid product
so if you have large pores blackheads oily skin
acne this is probably going to help your skin
I have tried so many products on the market
and I still haven't found a salicylic acid
product that works as well as this on my skin
this is probably a bit less budget friendly than
your standard skincareaddiction product but if
you look at it per mL it's actually really good
value because this bottle just does not run out
the paula's Choice brand philosophy matches
really well with skincareaddiction there's a
lot of emphasis on science maybe some studies are
taken a bit too seriously but Paula was such a
Pioneer in educating consumers about skin care and
these products are just really really good next
we have the ordinary's niacinamide
and this is again another really
skincareaddiction friendly Brand
This is actually I think the ordinary's
top seller as well the whole brand is
really budget friendly and they really appeal to
that sort of person who cares about ingredients
I think they were also really important in
getting people to care about the science
behind skincare products because they have
these really technical names front and center
this product tends to be good for
people who have acne so again it
matches well with the skincareaddiction
demographic but it does tend to break some
some people out and some people become
scared of niacinamide because of this
I would definitely recommend trying
more products with niacinamide and not
dismissing all products with niacinamide
on the basis of this because I did that
and then I realized my skin actually loves
niacinamide it just doesn't love this product
it wasn't bad it was just you know meh
so I think this one I'm kind of hovering
between solid choice and that because I think
it doesn't work for a big enough proportion
of people I'm gonna put it in meh for now
the next one is the CeraVe salicylic acid
cleanser I think this is a good product for
people whose skin maybe can't quite tolerate
salicylic acid maybe they're using too many
irritating ingredients already if you're
using these acne products if you're using
different or tretinoin or if you're also using
benzoyl peroxide then maybe your skin is a bit
too irritated to go for something like
the paula's choice two percent BHA you
can just get a little bit of salicylic
acid and not dry out your skin too much
as a cleanser I think it is too drying for
everyday use even on my skin which is more
oily it did feel quite dehydrating it
also does smell a bit and on my skin
I didn't find that it did very much and I
think that's just because I use so much of
the Paula's Choice two percent BHA there's only
so much that a salicylic acid cleanser can add
I'm going to put this on the
solid choice because I think
it is a really useful product for a lot of people
number nine is the Neutrogena Hydro Boost
water gel when Neutrogena came out with
the Hydro Boost range it was really
exciting because there just weren't
many of these sort of Asian textured
moisturizers on the market what I mean
by Asian textured is that it's got that
sort of lightweight gel texture that's
really hydrating without feeling heavy
and this is just amazing for oily skin
now this product does have a little
bit of a stronger fragrance than I
prefer American Products in general tend
to be a bit more heavily fragranced than
Australian products and as far as I know it
doesn't come in fragrance free I'm going to
put this in solid Choice unless of
course you have a fragrance problem
next one is the cosrx Advanced
snail 96 mucin Power essence
I'm actually kind of surprised this
is so high at the same time I'm not
that surprised because skincareaddiction's
sister subreddit is Asianbeauty there's a
lot of crossover between users this has
been a classic for a really long time
I think it was launched maybe 2014-2015 and
it has been huge since then I've actually
been retrying this out properly for a video
that is coming out I think probably next week
my video schedule is super messed up at the
moment so that video is actually already live
so I'll save most of my comments for that but
this is a really good product lots of people
love it some people do react to it but again not
that many so I'm gonna put this in Holy Grail
our next product is la roche-posay cucaplast
baume this is going against straight to
the holy Grails this is my go-to product
for whenever my skin is really irritated
this is a really thick balm product that has lots
of soothing ingredients in it it's got B5 it's got
one of the centella derivatives madecassoside it's
just really good for when your skin is irritated
and can't really handle much helps when I have
a lot of chafing around my nose for example I'll
just slather this on and go to bed and the
next day my skin will just be a lot happier
I don't think I've ever finished a tube
of this a little does go a long way so
I think it does end up being pretty
good value even though La Roche posay
is probably maybe a little bit
above CeraVe in terms of budget
our next product is the Cetaphil
gentle skin cleanser now this one
is interesting because the cleanser that Cetaphil
had before this new version was actually
like a product that everyone kind of hated
the old version had a really short ingredients
list which is good if you have sensitive skin
you don't have to look through as many
ingredients to try to work out if you
can or can't use that product but it just
had a lot of ingredients that got demonized
so it had sodium lauryl sulfate which is a
surfactant that tends to be a bit harsher it
has fatty alcohols which some people think break
them out it had propylene glycol which sounds a
lot like ethylene glycol which is antifreeze
plus it had parabens so you'd get all these
infographics where estheticians were just
saying Cetaphil is toxic sludge which it isn't
again clean beauty is BS it is just a
misunderstanding of toxicology but there
are just a lot of easy reasons to pick
on it and it seemed kind of like they
hadn't updated the formula for a few decades
because it is a really old school formula
lots of people do like it and I think
there was probably a big outcry when
they did finally reformulate
it to this current version
now this new version I think is a bit of a
marketing dream at the moment because it just
has a whole bunch of ingredients that everyone
likes and nothing that's too easy to pick on
so they've taken out the SLS and
the parabens and they have this
really short ingredients list which
I think a lot of people like because
it's a little bit less intimidating
it feels a bit less stranger danger
there are some trendy actives in this
panthenol and niacinamide so vitamin B5
and B3 which I think are just really easy
to Market there are some nice hydrating
ingredients so glycerin and pantolactone and
yeah it's just a really inoffensive formula
again it is non-foaming so it's very similar
to that CeraVe hydrating cleanser so I think
this is probably trying to compete with that I
find it really inoffensive it's fine it's not
like a joy to use but it's really good so
I'm going to put it again in solid Choice
all right our next one is the ordinary
hyaluronic acid I think hyaluronic acid
has been trending for such a long time
it's just pushed a lot in Western skin
care it's a humectant moisturizer that grabs
onto water and keeps your skin hydrated by
sort of trapping water sticking to
water and keeping it on your skin
I don't think most people need a separate
hyaluronic acid product I think the main
complaint that people have about it
that I agree with is that it's just
a bit boring as a humectant there are
so many other ingredients that can do
more like glycerin is in so many things
and it's a really good humectant already
there's the snail essence which is just
a heavy hitter this is just a bit meh
so yeah I don't hate it but it's just
gonna go in this area where I probably
wouldn't recommend it but if you're using it
I'm not going to like knock it out of your hand
then we have the ordinary's
glycolic acid toner this one
I have mixed feelings on because
this is a bit strong so it says
seven percent but it doesn't really feel
like a seven percent glycolic acid product
I think a lot of people end up over using
this and then burning their skin a lot but
I think it is really good for people who want
a stronger chemical exfoliant and it is such
good value it is a huge bottle I've actually
been using this on other parts of my body I've
been using it under my arms as a deodorant I
know some people also use it on their scalp
to like exfoliate their scalp so yeah this is
a good product I'm going to say solid Choice
as long as you're using it properly and
you're not yeah drowning your face in it
all right number 15 is the CeraVe healing
ointment this is not officially available
in Australia but I do like it so back in 2015 the
idea of covering your face in Vaseline overnight
became really popular on Reddit there was some
posts about becoming a slug which was kind of
funny because people were into snail at the
time as well so yeah that seems to be the
origin of the term slugging although people
have been doing this for a much longer time
Tiara Willis who is an esthetician
I think she's most active on Twitter
I think she came up with the term
glazed donut which is a bit nicer
than slugging and yeah it's to do with
using CeraVe healing ointment as you'd
expect the main ingredient in this is
petroleum jelly which is thick and it's
the gold standard occlusive ingredient so it's
really good at sealing in water into your skin
there's a bunch of other stuff mixed into
this as well so you've got CeraVe standard
ceramides there's also hyaluronic
acid to hydrate and there's a bunch
of other occlusives in this as well
I think they're added there so that
this makes it a bit more spreadable
than your standard petroleum jelly
I think I'm going to shuffle some of my
ratings I'm going to put the glycolic acid
toner up to Holy Grail I actually can't
think of another chemical exfoliant that
is this budget friendly and I think that
is rare enough that it can go under there
and then I'm gonna put the CeraVe
healing ointment into solid choice
because I personally am not a huge fan
of slugging on my skin it's fine for
other people's skin but I just find it a
bit messy on my pillowcase and yeah I've
got other products that I prefer for that
which is yeah the la roche posay cicaplast
so there are my rankings of these 15 as you would
expect nothing is not for anyone because these
are like the most popular 15 products on a really
big website I'll put the link to the full list in
the description so you can check all of that out
if you want yeah let me know what you think of
these products and my rankings was I really really
harshly unfair to like the ordinary's niacinamide
let me know if you have any ideas for other
ranking videos if you want to nerd out more I
recently did a video where I talked about my whole
approach to skincare and I will see you next time